[Music]
the Department of the Interior is
kicking off its first ever doggy day
this morning secretary Ryan Denki showed
up to his first day of work in March
riding a horse that was when animals
were not allowed now chip rate is inside
the Department of Interior in Washington
where dogs are welcome chip good morning
well good morning baby gray and rainy
outside but in here in the Interior
Department lobby it's all smiles and
puppy dogs as you can see secretaries
inky who is joining us back here says
this is the first federal department to
go dog friendly and he's confident it's
going to raise morale and reduce stress
interior Secretary's inky's dog
ragnar is no stranger to his office hey
hey Ragnar look Ragnar smells my dog
there it is yeah Ragnar is our
ambassador to happiness the Department
of Interior the former Navy SEAL
commander turned congressman says Ragnar
is allowed to join him at work but he
wants the employees at his department to
have the same benefit I mean if you're
having a bad day Ragnar is really good
at making the day just a little bit
better
Zink he announced his intent to hold
doggie days at interior soon after his
first day on the job
he's been counting down on Twitter
posting employee photos of some of the
80 dogs of the department expected to
show up today I wanted our department to
be inviting how we have terrific people
and I want the work environment to be
one that that people really want to go
to work Megan bloom grin is thrilled to
be able to bring her dog Daisy to work
there's definitely a buzz around the
department it's pretty exciting to be
able to have your dog at work dogs in
Washington DC offices is not a new idea
presidents have been bringing their dogs
to work for generations president Trump
is the first president not to have a dog
in the White House in nearly 130 years
if the president asks you should I get a
dog what would you tell him absolutely
and I didn't let him borrow Roger to her
test trial for a while as long as I get
him back
nationwide 7% of employers now allow
dogs in the workplace
it's morale it's people are comfortable
with dogs but there are some concerns
including allergies and disrupting the
work environment not everyone loves dogs
and so we're respectful that to Zinke
said all of the dogs that come to work
must be housebroken have their shots and
be well-behaved so if the dog thing
works out our cats next well we'll take
it one step at a time okay now let me
ask raise your hand if your morale is
already higher than usual all right
there you go fantastic and nor am i
morale is sky-high because this is Lulu
Lulu come on come on Lulu up come on
good girl she is she is one of my three
dogs and she's very beautiful as you can
see and she's got her sporty raincoat on
and she's happy to be with all these
dogs and by the way you asked if
secretaries inky's dog is a Havanese
that is exactly what it is a Cuban dog
going from onna Chief Justice Roberts
has a Havanese too now I have a Havanese
mix chip that's great yeah chip is like
come on Lulu don't embarrass daddy get
up yeah very nice it was never like
secretaries inky when he said ambassador
of happiness that's that is what dogs do
for you unconditional love I love dogs